hey guys welcome back to the channel for
another exclusive
collider interview this one is for the
new movie dreamland and i have carrie
condon with me today
how are you doing hey not bad thank you
congrats on the movie
we did want to go back a little and
cover some of your filmography leading
up to dreamland though and i wanted to
kind of go back to i guess
almost the very beginning of your career
because i know you worked
a lot with martin mcdonough and you two
are close friends so is there anything
about working with him and working with
the material that he writes that you
find influencing your craft today
wow that's a good question um
well yeah because when i was very young
that was one of the first things that i
did was
at two of his plays and the second one
was like a year and a half that i
did it for um i guess it influenced me
because
i all the preparation that you do for a
play like you
kind of rehearse and you go through all
the dialogue and you you know make your
decisions
prior to doing it i sort of
still do that and i'm very strict with
dialogue like i don't
change the dialogue without asking or i
don't
add in lines like in theater you it's
you have to do it exactly the way it's
written and so i kind of still have that
discipline with the script
and where i don't veer from what's
written and i kind of hate when they ask
you to do
i really bugs me when they uh
very seldom they say you know
ad lib and you're like no i'm not at
living because you know sometimes people
add leave when they go on
for like two minutes and it's like well
this is just like this isn't good for
the story
so i like being straight to dialogue and
i suppose
when i did one of martin's plays the
lieutenant divinish more
i was the only girl with the cast of all
men
and i think that sort of benefited me
going forward because the character that
i played was really feisty and tough and
she had gone over her shoulder all the
time
so i'm very good in an all-male
environment
and i'm that benefited me i kind of
know how to work it to my advantage
and i that was good for me just because
i'm
curious now have you ever worked
opposite another actor who prefers to
improvise an ad-lib and if so how do you
adjust to that
it's not jesus i don't want to cut off
my nose despite my face and say i don't
like improvising
i do but sometimes i think it's like
well is that because the script is badly
written that you want me to improvise
you know
it's different if it's the whole thing
is improvising i don't know i just
wanted to suspect that it's
slack on the writer's path i don't think
i can't think of an instance off the top
of my head but i know i experienced one
because you're standing there going okay
this is just going on too long
this is going to end up in the cotton
room floor and we're just indulging you
yeah you have to forward the story or
what's the point
so i can't think of the top of my head
but i can recall being vexed
about it so i'm sure i did experience in
it i just don't know what one it was on
well it's understandable to have that
read on it i
have a rome question for you next
because we have a lot of rome fans over
at collider
and in particular i want to know what it
was like working on such a big
production back then because nowadays
it's kind of the norm for hbo shows to
be like
gigantic like that so what's something
that kind of wowed you
back then that has become the norm in
the industry now
yikes um i suppose i was very young at
the time and very
like i had a lot of experience bar the
theater that i had done
and some like small movies so
i don't think i fully took it in as much
as i i think if i did i would have got
very nervous and it would have kind of
overwhelmed
me but i suppose the costume aspect of
it and the props because
they made every costume by hand
and the lady the costume designer was
like flying to india for fabric
and then they had all these amazing
really old italian ladies like sewing
beads and
so every costume was so beautiful and
like i'd wear it in one scene and that'd
be it and i'd never wear it again
and all the jewelry was handcrafted
by this guy who's good at metal and you
know just
and all that everything was made from
scratch so i that kind of wowed me that
there was
so many people working behind the scenes
and
um old italian people who you imagine
like you know in high fashion like
beading laces and stuff
and that kind of wowed me at the time i
remember because when i would take off
the costume i would just be like oh
that's so sad
it's like all that work and i'm never
gonna wear it again
did you get to keep anything from that
set i kept one thing
yeah i kept one thing but you know i'm
obviously never really gonna wear it
so but i kept it for you know
sentimental reasons
yeah it's nice to know it has a good
home and is appreciated at least
you know i wonder where all the other
costumes are they're probably in a box
somewhere
i will say i i'm a big fan of uh prop
and
costume auctions i shouldn't be spending
money on all that stuff but i just can't
help it so it's nice to know that
some some of those things find good
homes that way home
i didn't even know what they have though
there's a couple things lurking in the
background here tell me your favorite
thing that you got
i i'm really bad with the mirrored frame
it's this guy
right here is uh deputy dewey's uh
tag his name badge from scream for
no
you should go and uh browse prop store
the website
it's it's got some good stuff there oh
thank you perhaps around
so this next one i have a feeling you're
asked about fairly often and it's about
voicing friday because i'm just curious
how exactly do you come to voice a
character like that is it something that
they offer to you or do you kind of get
the opportunity
to audition and just wonder you know
what is this and what does this
opportunity hold for the future
i hadn't a notion when i went in for it
what i was going up for
to be honest but the casting lady kind
of had
called me in on a lot of jobs and i'd
gotten very close but i didn't get them
so i kind of suspect she was throwing me
a bone
a little bit because it was probably
like this poor girl like christ she
can't catch a break
so she called me in and was like don't
you know it's no big she didn't say what
it was for or anything but just like
just read this paragraph in like english
accent american accent and then my own
accent
so i was like okay i'll just read it and
didn't think twice about it and then
they called me and they were like oh yes
who's this part in avengers and can you
do it in your own accent
and i was yeah so it was such a great
opportunity i never would have thought
to have done voice
at all it was i had never done voice
work or anything like that
so and i didn't think it would lead to
so many movies either i thought it was
just a one-off
um job so it was great
one might think something like that is
you go in the booth
and you just do your thing and you get
out what is a part of the process that
really speaks to your creative desires
um well first of all because i've never
done it before so that was the big pull
i was like excited to see
and it's a lot harder than you think
actually like i think voiceover actors
are
they're really good it's a totally
different skill
um a lot of the time i was doing it to a
blank screen
because either they didn't want to like
show me what it was
or it wasn't fully done you know they
hadn't added all the visual effects
because i kind of do it at the end of
the
job after they've shot it and they're
putting in all the special effects
so it's kind of pieced together and so
they have to kind of explain
like what came before and what's coming
afterwards so
you really have to use your imagination
and go okay so how high are the stakes
like is this the last battle of the
movie or is it like the first battle you
know so you can kind of know how much to
give
but the last one when he died was like
oh my god yeah i've watched that
that uh sequence over and over and over
again and it gets me every single time
i know and at the time too i was like
but there's hope
right i mean like he's not totally dead
and they kind of looked at me like
i thought oh my god i knew my gravy
train had just come to a halt
and so they said do it like it's the
saddest thing
say it like it's the saddest thing
you've ever said and i was like well
that won't be [ __ ] hard like he's
just
like it's all over that's the one had to
go there yeah that was it was such a
great opportunity really was
i i adore that franchise quite a bit and
i'm i'm eager to see it grow even more
the next one for you better call saul
for this one i was
reading something that you said about
the process and just in terms of it
being a learning curve for you
so now i'm wondering for anybody else
out there who might book a super cool
show like that
and get to jump in for just a handful of
episodes what advice would you give them
to
make the most of the experience on the
role oh
that's a good question too um i would
say
be completely prepared and not nervous
because like they just don't have time
for somebody being nervous
like you just i'm glad it came at that
point in my career to be honest with you
because if it had come early in my
career i think i would have over thought
it and i would have been very nervous
but like jonathan is very strong person
and he's very prepared and he's
like ready to do it right and take one
there's no like warming up and
so i would say just be very confident in
your choices and be prepared and don't
be nervous
because tv goes very quickly and they
don't have time for ten
takes and they don't have time for you
making mistakes
so you have to be able to cool as a
breeze come in and i guess
saying not be nervous is because it's
not really about
my character the story is about
jonathan's character
and so i think maybe swallow your ego a
little bit and remember
that you're facilitating the story of a
main character you're not the main
character
so i have to kind of remember that
how can i make jonathan's job as easy as
possible
and as stress-free as possible because
he's going to be working when i'm going
home
he's got more days to do and he's older
than me too and
there has to be like a respect for an
older actor i think
um as there should be obviously he's got
more years more experience on me
so make the person that you're working
with who's the lead
their job as easy as possible and if
that means like shutting up in the
makeup trailer not saying anything
then shut up in the makeup trailer and
don't say anything like whatever they
want
you give and that's your job i think
with that in mind beyond just maybe not
talking in the makeup trailer
what is something that you could do for
him or you've done for him
on set as a scene partner that you hope
one day someone does for you
well he's pretty easy to work with now
to be honest with you you don't have to
help him that much like
i help him but i mean i chat to him in
between takes and things like that you
know
um let me think what have i done for him
that i hope somebody would do for me
well there you go just that
know your lines and know your lines and
don't be taken up all the time and
thinking of wanting to think about your
character very
much like again be prepared
come in and deliver something really
great that somebody can work off of
and remember it's not about you it's not
your show
that's i think i that's when it works
best
too i think is when you feel like you're
partners as opposed to one person wants
to overtake the scene it's kind of
that's when it becomes a bit like
well it's a dance really between the two
of us so
absolutely that's a hard one i
can't think of anything amazing i've
done from to be honest
i'm sure i'm sure he's aware of it i
could probably ask him this question and
he'll give me a laundry list of things
one day
oh he probably tells you such a gent
so i got one more for you before we go
into dreamland because
everyone's going kind of crazy right now
over
fincher because we're all really looking
forward to mank and i know things didn't
pan out on the show
that you worked with him on but is there
anything about your experience working
with david fincher that
i guess wowed you were something that
was super unique about his process with
working with actors
oh my gosh i'm so glad you brought that
up thank you first of all like i've
always wanted to work with him because i
heard stories that he does loads of
takes
and i was like i would do billions of
takes for just the sake of being in the
room with david fincher
i am such a big fan of his work
and i like to try different things and
different experiences
so yeah no joke he does
so many takes i had a scene where i had
to smoke a cigarette for every take
on a phone call and we did 76 takes
so i must have smoked i think i smoked
some real ones sometimes just because i
was like i need a real cigarette
and take like 50 or something but then
it would be herbals
and then real ones and herbals and i
think
uh i loved it i would do it again in a
heartbeat
i loved every minute of it and it didn't
feel like
um in the beginning i was a little
worried that like
oh is it because i did it wrong or am i
really [ __ ] is that
why we're on take 27 because like this
is not good like what am i doing wrong
and then you realize no it's not that
he's just gonna keep going just keep
going it's nothing
just keep doing it keep offering
different stuff and just go with it
and it starts to become kind of surreal
because you get your appointed like take
60 or something where you're like i
don't even know what i'm saying like
just words are just coming out and i
don't even know like if it's making
sense or
is it it was and he was all very nice
about it too
there wasn't a feeling of like no do it
again
he you know he would come in at the end
to go thank you very much moving on and
you're like
i was on a drift at that point going
okay we're moving on
so i love this i loved every minute of
it and he was
so smart with every department um
it was kind of like michael mann it was
that same thing of a
director who knew everything about
lighting knew everything about costumes
knew everything
they just knew the whole uh
everything about filmmaking and it's
really amazing being around someone like
that
i am a big fan so none of this surprises
me
i am also a mighty big fan of margot
robbie in general but also
what she's doing in the producing sphere
right now so on dreamland
what is it like on that set that signals
to you that this is a lucky chat
production
you know i'll be honest the thing that
really shocked me
was and this is kind of weird to say
that it shocked me but when i
wrapped and finished my last day
margaret wasn't there but she wasn't in
the scene so i didn't think twice about
it she was at the time promoting um
i think it was the ice skating movie
tell me the name
yes i think it might have been that i
hope it was then i might be getting on
because she was promoting a movie in l.a
on her days off
right so i was like that's so busy like
shooting a lead role and then your days
off flying to l.a to do promotion on
that
she sent me an email the night i
rapped saying i'm so sorry i couldn't be
there
like you were so and all these
compliments about my performance and i
just thought
oh my god like it was so classy because
i thought where did she get the time
like i'm you know what i mean or even
like think about
that to do that because between flying
and promoting and then learning our own
lines and performing allison and then
doing such a great job
for the role of allison i just found it
really classy
and kind of um i hadn't seen that sort
of
behavior from an actress or maybe a
producer in
a really long time it was so beautiful
and it was nice to get
to be honest exactly why i asked that
question i feel like we
need more i mean not just incredible
filmmakers but sport systems in this
business like that
so next i want to ask you about working
with miles
because i feel like you can read the
script for a movie like this
and maybe not get the full impact of the
vision he's about to bring to screen
so what was it about him especially this
being his second feature
film with your early conversations that
kind of gave you the confidence that he
could pull a production like this off
well the first confidence thing came
from the fact that margot was attached
and so i knew like she's not just gonna
hire any
dumb [ __ ] to direct it do you know what
i mean i knew that was like he obviously
was
had something but i asked him for a lot
of references when i was kind of
preparing for it before i got to new
mexico and he gave me
pictures to look at the lounge door at
the
lounge has some beautiful pictures from
that era
and then there was some books that he
recommended to me
and there was like poetry books the
collected works of billy the kid is one
of the books
and then the worst hard times timothy
egan book
and so immediately i knew that like this
guy is
smart it's like i know it sounds
terrible like he reads books nowadays
you're like that
is you know a rare receiver so
um because he's so young too you know
what i mean he really was so impressive
and then i asked him was there music
that he was listening to or music
that could help me like set the tone of
where
what he was thinking so he'd be on the
same page and he sent me some little
excerpts of music and he had composed
the music
i know i couldn't believe it
i was actually kind of jealous because i
was like is there anything that you're
not
good at but it was this beautiful music
that he had composed
to sort and it was the same it was so
the exact same
kind of tone and vibe that i had
thought of when i read it a lonely kind
of a sad
um tune that it was the same as what i
had been thinking
so that's when i knew that like he was
a very artistic person and also that the
fact that he was young
i don't really let that kind of
influence me because you can meet an
old soul who's very young
and he wasn't cocky you know the way
there's an arrogance of
youth and sometimes people can be very
young and they're talking like they know
everything and i'm like i've worked with
dave fincher and like some amazing
people
and so stop doing that like you really
don't know
everything and that's how you become
really good is by being open to learning
but he was not a bit like that he was
just not a bit there was just really
um he was very open to other people's
ideas he was very
generous of spirit and that's why i
think the dp
did such a beautiful job because he was
able to let him
do a beautiful job so there are some
frames in this movie that i don't
think i'm ever going to forget i'm like
mildly obsessed with the shower scene in
particular and how he cracks
the bed and what it says about their
journey it's just being able to do so
much storytelling just in the way you
capture something is
a really special technique there it was
and that's a good director is letting
great people heads of department like
do what they're good at and stepping
back and
like orchestrating it and so i could see
that he was doing that so
what was the vibe like on set in general
because you know you just described it
as a
a lonely and sad kind of film and it is
that to a degree but you seem like a lot
of fun and even though
travis is so intense in this movie i've
heard you know stories about how he's a
good time too so what happens when the
cameras stop
rolling do you guys kind of snap out of
it and everything lightens up
it felt like a very young young
vibe on it i would say like it felt like
i was kind of starting my career again
because a lot of the crew were very
young
and so i kind of liked that
it didn't feel super serious and super
like we have to deliver oh my god
there's so much money riding on this
it felt like we was like a student film
in a way like we're in the middle of
nowhere
and i i suppose when i say sad like the
movie isn't really sad i just feel like
my character kind of carried an air of
sadness but i think i'm always drawn to
that a little bit
personally in movies anyways um
travis yeah he's not a bit serious he's
totally joking all the time like no
there was no there was no seriousness
coming from him it was yeah it was just
very enjoyable and very
um small a small unit and a small
vibe to the whole thing so i have to
wind down with you
but i wanted to end on something a
little off topic because i was reading
your comments
about hollywood parties and i got a kick
out of them and i also appreciated just
how frank you were
about the whole thing so i want to turn
that idea on its head
put the control in your hands if you had
the opportunity to throw your own
hollywood party name
i don't know the dress code food being
served parting gift whatever it is what
would you pick
oh oh my god will i
not invite a lot of people and i would
say
no cell phones no post and selfies
none of that i would say you've to pay
to come and the money goes to an animal
charity or a children's charity
and you have to say you have to tip the
waiter
and if somebody doesn't say please or
thank you to the waiter you get out
but i think nobody would come to this
party because i'd be like i would come
to that party
and then i suppose what else would i
have
um i'd invite a lot of people who were
who people kind of are
are controversial and people sort of um
try and cancel and things like that
i think i would try and be a little bit
um forgiving and understanding and see
gray areas with people and that people
aren't all bad
so maybe i'd be to be a they'll be all
sorts
at it but yeah i guess manners would be
a big thing
and yeah and maybe you'd have to get
public transport or something
there maybe something like that we'd
have to keep it very like
go back to where you came from kind of
thing i'm into this idea put me on the
guest list please
you so much for your time today and for
everybody out there who now wants to
catch dreamland because of course you do
it's going to be available on vod
november 17th
check it out we'll see you soon